pas manquer le reste aussi adorable et
puisqu'elle aussi prennent soin d'elle
et soyez belle tous les jours bonne fête
à toutes les mamans
j'ai normalement et qu'elle a fait des
gros bisous les jours
les gentils avec moi et j'ai pas envie
qu'elle parte fait cette maman bisous ce
petit message pour trois mamans tu m'as
donné la vie
tu as toujours été avec moi dans les
bons moments comme dans les mauvais tu
as ce petit sixième sens qui fait que tu
vois tout de suite quand ça va pas même
sans le dire donc pour tous à cette
angoisse est très fort et je te dis je
t'aime maman elle est gentille et
intelligente et fort merci pour tous ces
cadeaux ça me fait du bien et je te
remercie wolf est devant moi chérie et
bien tout d'abord je souhaiterais une
très bonne et heureuse fête des mamans à
ma maman claudine qui est parmi nous
toujours et que je lui souhaite longue
vie et je souhaite
de profiter lambeaux avec elle et je
profite pour souhaiter une très bonne et
heureuse fête des mamans à toutes les
mamans de la martinique est bien entendu
à toutes les mamans du monde que celle
qu'ils soient malades que celle qui soit
en forme et qu'elle reste en forme et je
fais tout plein de bisous à toutes les
mamans de la martinique
je t'aime maman parce que tu es très
gentil avec loin tu me laisses faire des
choses qui a peut-être du malheur ne
font pas avec leurs enfants et c'est ce
qu'ils aiment bien avec toi et pour tous
âges étaient d'ibn ferment je vais
toujours tes mais qu est-ce qu à la fin
de mes jours
la minute d'amour vous a été présentée
par le centre commercial place d'armes